[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous lecture on the
castillonos theorem on deflections
at the very end i had mentioned that i
had finished
the theory part and that we would be
going on to problems
but i realized that before i can
actually go on to start solving problems
i'll have to lay some basic ground work
which will look
a bit like theory so uh so that i have
uh
i've titled today's lecture as polluted
to problems
okay so this is neither really theory
but not really
problems something in between uh
so our intention here is to use
the castigliano's theorem of deflections
which was as written last time
the to find out the the deflection
uh along the direction
of a force uh
applied at a certain point which is
represented by this uf bar
we have to use this derivative with uh
of this u dash which is the
complementary
energy now we had also mentioned in the
previous lecture that
uh this u dash for hookian materials
uh that is for linear elastic materials
uh
for linear elastic materials we had
mentioned that
uh this
u dash is equal to u which is the strain
energy
and uh mostly we will be dealing with
the kind of problems which
uh which are made up of these linear
elastic materials
uh in fact linear elastic isotropic
materials uh
so we won't be bothered too much with
this distinction between u dash and u
but we will be also solving uh problems
uh at least one illustrative example
involving a non-linear material for
which
uh we'll have to go down the root of
using the u dash
um but even before that okay if even for
let's say we use
we want to use an inelastic material
where we can use the strain energy
directly you
uh we have to be a little bit careful in
the usage
okay so now towards that and you first
note
that this u is equal to
uh the integration of the uh the strain
energy
density which is per volume
like this uh all that is fine but
what exactly is the form of the u that
we should be using
uh especially when we are interested in
solving beam problems
okay now uh
some of you may already be familiar with
the with the operational bits of it
uh but
what i wish to highlight here uh is that
we should not be directly jumping to any
kind of
uh formula uh which we may know from our
undergraduate days
for example if i asked you about the for
the expression of the strain energy many
of you may
actually jump uh to the to the
so called famous formula that this u
naught is something like
half sigma epsilon okay so we have to be
a little bit careful
before carelessly writing something like
that okay
so what i will do here is i will write
down the expression
for the strain energy density u naught
for a linear elastic isotropic material
uh in this fashion okay so let me write
write this down
and then we can go into a discussion of
this so
[Music]
uh
here this lambda and g are the lamy
parameters
which we had discussed back in our
course of applied elasticity
uh here this ie
is the first invariant of string
this this roman 2 e
is the second invariant of string i
repeat
these two are the first and the second
in variance
of string there is no third invariant of
string involved here likewise
this can be equivalently represented
in this fashion
1 by twice e i 1 square
minus 2 into 1 plus nu
i2 where i1
and i2 are the first
and the second in variance of stress
so in the previous line ie and this 2e
where the
first and the second in variance of
strain here in this line
i1 and i2 are the first and the second
invariance
of stress of course this capital e is
the young's modulus
this nu is the poison's ratio
so where do we get this expressions from
okay
so that is a discussion which i will
will go into these discussions a bit
later
because i do not wish to break the flow
of
the current discussion where i want to
go into
a form of the strain energy which will
be
actually usable while solving problems
of involving beams okay based on uh
where we apply castigliano's theorem
okay so uh i'll
cover this part in this lecture itself
but first uh i would like to
proceed with the uh proceed with the
with the strain energy as it is now if
we consider this
the second uh bit okay the second
formula
then uh especially considering
thin rods okay mostly in the case
of typical loading scenarios like
bending
uh the only stress uh which will be
dominant
okay is the one involving the sigma one
1. okay you understand this i1
it is equal to sigma 1 1 plus sigma 2
2 plus sigma 3 3 that's sigma 1 1 we are
talking about
the rest of the normal stresses as well
as the shear stresses
which would be involved in this
expression of i2
those are non-dominant in such a
scenario
okay so uh
so for or
thin rods
under maybe exhale loading or bending
okay let's consider bending because this
will be the
this will be the case for which we'll
develop our formula
uh subsequently for thin roads under
bending
uh it is the sigma one one which is
uh dominant okay
sigma one one is dominant over
everything else
which means that u naught
it basically reduces to 1 by twice e
sigma 1 1 square because you understand
i 1
is equal to sigma 1 1 plus sigma 2 2
plus sigma 3
3 if sigma 1 1 is dominant we don't have
to bother about sigma 2 2 and sigma 3
3 and this is only what remains
similarly this
i 2 would involve sigma 1 1 sigma 2 to
that those kinds of products but
since for all intents and purposes sigma
2 2
sigma 3 3 they are considered 0 so also
the shear stress terms
this won't contribute anything to the
final result here
okay now
for the strain energy of an entire beam
we are going to use this
and then we can directly use
what we have obtained in the previous
page i'm going to write this as sigma
i can write this as sigma 1 1 or if you
if you understand that
the one direction maps with the x
direction the familiar x direction from
you know considering a rectangular
cartesian coordinate system
so this is like that
integrated over the entire volume now
for
a beam okay for a beam
uh we know from our undergraduate
studies that
for this kind of a simple scenario uh
especially based on the euler bernoulli
hypothesis
and i'm not going to go into the details
of that uh
this sigma can be expressed
using the pending formula the bending
stress formula
or the or the more famously called
flexure formula
in terms of the bending moment now
this is a very very important point to
note here that
the bending moment so we understand that
this sigma
is m y
by i okay you will get a plus sign or a
minus sign here
depending on the choice of your
coordinate system but as you can see
we do have a square present here so it
really doesn't matter whether
you use the minus sign or the plus sign
what is important however
is to realize that since we'll be
carrying out this
integration over the entire volume which
means along the
we have to integrate over the length of
the beam also in addition to its
uh to an integration over the cross
sectional area
uh and there is a possibility
that this bending moment will have a
certain variation
along the length of the beam so we have
to be a little bit careful here
so what we'll do is we'll decompose this
overall integral volume in this fashion
so first integration
is over the over the length of the beam
and we say that this uh this
lengthwise direction is the x direction
the x from the rectangular cartesian
coordinate system
and this area integration
and what we'll have here is so i take
this
2e i can take it outside
okay for the timing and keeping it
outside
this sigma is it gives us m square
y square by i square
the first integration is with respect to
the area
the second is with respect to this x
coordinate
so this dx correspond to the 0 to l and
this da correspond to this integration
over the a
now please note
that this i square is a
is a constant for the
for the area so if we actually consider
prismatic cross sections
this can very well be taken outside this
outside this area okay
in fact for prismatic cross sections we
can have this i
i square coming out of this integration
also
but for now we'll just keep it outside
this area integration
okay uh because in general we can have
non-prismatic cross sections also and in
uh and you will do a problem like that
uh however please note that we
cannot strictly cannot take this m out
of
out of this 0 to l integration
okay so we take the m outside also of
this area integration
no problem there so we keep it like this
this is y square d a
dx now what this thing is
if you think about it you'll realize
that this is nothing but the second
moment of area
which is just this i okay so this
integration over the entire area
y square d a that represents the
second moment of area so what we have
is this thing
and usually this is written as
okay and we'll see an application of
this
of this formula when we want to find out
the deflections in response to point
forces applied on cantilever beams
on simply supported beams so on and so
forth there are and there will be
certain
um certain things to be careful about
there also
but now now so this is the this is the
thing uh which i wanted to present
as a uh as one of the main things in our
prelude in our basic ground work before
launching into problems
okay so from that sense uh this is done
but let me
not forget about what i had promised in
the previous page
that i would be discussing a bit about
these things that i have written
how do we arrive at these
expressions for the strain energy
density
okay so so let's have a discussion about
that
regarding the form of the strain energy
density
all right so we have already seen
earlier
that sigma ij is equal to
[Music]
del u naught del epsilon i j
we have already seen that now
many of the things that we'll be
discussing subsequently okay
some of the crucial things that we'll be
discussing uh will be based
on our understanding of this formula
but uh first of all you note that
uh this
u naught okay and i have also mentioned
this earlier
this u naught is dependent
on deformations okay the strain energy
will be dependent
on deformations
additionally it may also be dependent on
the temperature on the heat flux
but for at least within our scope of
advanced mechanics of solids
we shall not be bothered with those
kinds of dependencies
so uh this dependence of the u naught on
deformations
we will uh formulate that by writing
the u naught to be a function
of epsilon i j so
all the deformations all the information
in the deformations
we capture it within this epsilon i j
so just a brief note before we before i
say anything else
this little discussion that i'm about to
uh about to embark on
this is basically a very very
summarized uh
non-formal uh non-rigorous
uh discussion of what we usually have
in a proper continuum mechanics course
i mean the scope of advanced mechanics
of solids
uh i mean it certainly doesn't allow us
to launch into that kind of extensive
discussions
but if you are really interested in that
in those kinds of discussions i will
provide a link
to a very good set of lectures
in the details of this youtube video and
you can
i can take a look at that okay for now
we we stay happy with this limited
discussion
but i hope that even with this limited
discussion it will give you
some um some idea
uh with the underlying concepts okay so
to proceed forward
uh one very crucial thing to note here
is that uh
there is a little bit of an issue when
we say that
the strain energy density is dependent
on the
strains because you see these strain
components epsilon ij
as we have seen already in our course of
applied elasticity
it is very much dependent so epsilon i j
so these strain components
are dependent
on the choice of coordinate systems
on the choice of our coordinate system
however our u naught
that is a physical quantity
that's a physical truth about the system
under consideration
so how can this physical quantity be
dependent
on the choice of the coordinate system
so it must be
independent of the choice of the
coordinate systems
it should be that way okay
now you see where the issue is on the
one hand we are saying that u naught
should be depend should be a function of
this epsilon i j
and on the other hand there is this
apparent discrepancy
where these uh these strain components
are
something dependent on the choice of the
coordinate system but u naught
we want that wanted to be independent of
the choice of the coordinate system
okay so this apparent discrepancy that
we have here
how can we resolve it okay so there is
an apparent discrepancy here
okay so this is this is something
dangerous
okay so here it is independent here it
is dependent
so something has to be fixed here how
can you fix it
so uh if you think about it we
there is a way out okay so in one of our
live sessions
uh that i had just today
had asked the questions to the students
and very nicely
two of them had come up with the with
the answer that
one of them said that
suppose we we require that u naught is
dependent on
the principal strains because as we know
the principal strings
are independent of the choice of the
coordinate system
so that's a very nice answer and another
student said that perhaps
we can involve the strain in variance so
that answer regarding the strain invents
that is the official textbook answer
uh and the and of course the other
answer is also correct that the
principal strains because uh we know
that the principal strains are indeed
influenced or dependent only on the
strain in variance in fact back in our
course of applied elasticity we have
done some problems and we had discussed
this particular aspect so what to going
forward what
we'll say is that uh while our initial
thought
was that u naught would be a function of
epsilon i j but
reality but in reality to fix this
apparent discrepancy
between the uh dependence and the
independence of the choice of the
coordinate systems
what you have to really say is that u
naught is
actually a function of the string in
variance
so i e to e
and three e these are the
three string invariants
all right so far so good now
imagine that we wish to capture the
linear elastic behavior which is quite
common in many engineering systems
so we go back to our expression this
sigma ij is equal to del u naught
and del epsilon i j and we think
about it for a while you note
that uh if you
if you think a little bit carefully
about it you will see
that uh suppose this
u naught was just
linearly dependent on this 3e
i repeat suppose you imagine that this u
naught
has the simplest of dependences on this
three
through some kind of a linear
relationship maybe there is a term in
this
expansion of so till now we have not
written down this form of
uh how how how they are connected we
have just written that they would be
dependent on
this u naught would be dependent on this
but we have not written down the exact
form we don't know
yet but suppose we imagine that you that
u naught has the simplest of dependence
is on three maybe it is
just multiplied by a coefficient and
then three e
then what what will be the implication
of that implication is
that this 3e it is basically the
determinant
of the strain matrix okay it is the
determinant of the strain matrix
and each of the terms in it it involves
three of the strain components
okay so uh
so because this three e the third strain
invariant
it involves as its various terms
three of the strain components so these
are like
uh uh cubic powers so these involve
cubic powers of the string components
so if we do this kind of a first
derivative of
that cubic of those cubic terms you will
end up
with a relationship between the sigma
and this
and the epsilon which involves quadratic
terms
at best okay you will never
ever obtain linear terms okay so
this image so remember that this is
under the
under the supposition that u naught
is having um
a linear dependence on this 3 and if we
were to think that it is more than
linear then
it's even it's even a worse scenario
okay so even
even with a so let me go to the next
page
so we are remember that we are
considering the scenario for linear
elastic
behavior
for such materials okay if
u naught uh
just depended
on 3e
even linearly
then sigma ij
is equal to del u naught del epsilon i j
would
lead to a
independence
of sigma i j
on
quadratic terms of epsilon i j
quadratic in terms of of epsilon h
rather i should write
quadratic terms involving the strain
components
that would be more clear
and that happens because
involves cubic terms
of the strain components okay so
our conclusion is that at least for
linear elastic materials
what we had initially thought that u
naught would be dependent
on i 1 i 2 and i 3 that would be
wrong to assume and what we can what we
must conclude
is that the only dependence of u naught
should be on i e and 2 e
and please note that this is for again
for linear elastic materials
okay please note that our conclusion is
based
on the simplest possible linear
dependence of u naught
on 3e okay so if the scenario is
is like this for even for a linear
dependence on three
you can imagine that for uh for higher
order dependencies the scenario
would be even worse okay so certainly we
must not depend
on three e for this u naught
next let us consider the
ie that that is the first strain
invariant
okay again
you considered that u naught
depends on i e okay
so suppose if u naught indeed were to
depend on i e
linearly okay this is very important if
it were to depend on i
linearly then let's write this okay
so if
u naught depended
on i e linearly
sorry about that
then sigma ij is equal to
del u naught del epsilon i j
would produce
a constant term
what that means is that such a constant
term
would represent some non-zero value okay
so so this constant
term would represent
[Music]
a
represent a non-zero value
of stress
even in the absence of deformations you
think about it
even in the absence of deformations
so suppose you have sigma i j is equal
to 10
10 mega pascal so something like that if
you get such an answer
what it means is that even if your
epsilon i j
is not there then also sigma i j is
equal to 10
okay maybe you have something like sigma
x is equal to 10
mega pascal plus it has some
dependencies on
epsilon i j in in the other terms
because we have not yet talked about the
dependence on this 2e
we are only talking about that how u
naught is depending on
this ie the first training variant if it
so happens as we are saying
that it depends linearly on this first
strain invariant then it results in a no
in a in a constant term and such a
constant term it represents a non-zero
value of stress
even in the absence of any deformation
deformations means uh
in the absence of deformations means
epsilon i j is zero
now physically speaking there may be
certain situations
where such a thing is very much possible
okay
but that's not
extremely common in the typical
engineering situations that we are
interested in
and especially within the scope of
advanced mechanics of solids
we don't want to be bothered with such
kinds of
special situations okay we want to have
a situation
where you only have stresses when there
are deformations
okay so what we say is that
all the possible
all the possible physically
we will not consider such situations
okay we will not consider such
situations because it
uh it involves uh taking some uh some
special care
um on some other things okay
uh will not consider such situations
so if we do not really wish to consider
such situations
then what we had started out with here
that u naught dependent on this first
string invariant linearly
that is a no go okay so
we must conclude that this u naught
should be having such a form
that uh it does not depend
on the third string ingredient
it does not depend linearly on the first
string in variant that is the
conclusion okay so u naught
so u naught should not
depend on i e
linearly this is very important to note
please do not conclude
that it should not depend on ie okay
because you see the thing had gone
really bad
when we had taken even the linear
dependence on three but here we are
saying that if we take the linear
dependence on three then it is
bad but but it is very much possible
that u naught
can depend quadratically on this i e
and then we will be good because then it
would not lead to
this constant term
okay and in fact this is what we are
going to say in the next page
so overall what we can say is that
if uh so
so u naught
should depend on
on terms so this is the moral of the
you know of the of the story that we had
been talking about in the previous page
that u naught should depend on terms
that are quadratic
in the strain components
okay and such a thing can be ensured
okay
such a thing can be ensured
if our u naught
depends on ie
square and
directly on the linearly
on the uh
okay
so when i say depends on ie square and
2e i mean to say that it depends
directly or linearly
on this i square and 2e so basically
what i am saying here
is that i q naught should have the form
some constant term multiplied by
i e square plus some constant term
[Music]
times 2 e and now if you take this
thing and you you utilize
this
if you carry out this thing okay
substituting appropriately
the index notation expressions for this
i square
and this 2e and proceed it will involve
some steps
so if you proceed with that ultimately
you will
arrive at a relation between sigma ij
and this epsilon ij which are all linear
okay so ultimately if you proceed
if you proceed ultimately you will you
will end up
with sigma ij
linearly dependent
on epsilon ij components
now overall in this story uh i have not
uh i have actually hidden from you one
one little aspect that
in our arguments here uh
uh i mean the the way that we have
proceeded it is actually
not not just linear elastic that we are
that we would be arriving at here uh
this final expression
rather it will be the linear elastic
isotropic
okay but uh but the the arguments
uh involving the isotropic thing uh
would
would entail a little bit more
discussion so i'm not going into it
but i'm just telling you and you please
accept it on good faith that
that what the kind of steps that we are
proceeding with here that would
ultimately lead
to an expression of the sigma ij uh
that is not just linear in epsilon i j
but it will be of the form
that will also be isotropic i mean you
don't have to accept in good faith in
the sense that
you can actually do this thing and you
can see that yes it is it is indeed
isotropic but what i'm really hiding
from you is that
when i'm when i'm arguing for the case
that u naught depends on this i
square and 2e there i'm specializing to
the case of
uh in that argument itself i'm
specializing to the case of
uh isotropic okay so for non-isotropic
behavior for for an isotropic behavior
uh you'll have a little bit more general
expressions okay so let's not get into
all of those things uh and
interestingly if you if you actually
compare okay so whatever expression
you you get if you compare that
you compare the above
with the familiar expression of
linear elastic isotropic behavior which
we had discussed extensively
in our earlier course of applied
elasticity
that lambda epsilon kk
delta ij plus twice g
epsilon ij you will end up
you will end up with a kind of
expression
which we had discussed back here
okay so this this expression which we
had discussed back here
you will end up with that all right
so uh with this little prelude
uh okay but deep i mean
little but deep uh prelude uh
i think we are all set to tackle
problems and
we'll go on to problems okay thank you
very much
i'll end the video here